[Applaudissements]
bonjour bienvenue dans enquêtes de
région pour un numéro exceptionnel
mi-novembre débutait une mobilisation
contre le prix des carburants dix
semaines après avec les gilets jaunes
la france vit une crise sociale et
politique inédite sous la vème
république
au quotidien nos rédactions vous ont
rendu compte de ces événements et nous
avons décidé ce soir d'aller plus loin
avec des reportages et des invités pour
comprendre ce qui s'est passé est aussi
ce qui peut se passer maintenant avec un
grand débat qui s'ouvre est une
mobilisation qui continue avec nous sur
ce plateau pour en parler pour échanger
sabrina morio bonjour bonjour vous êtes
investi vous dans ce mouvement d gilet
jaune depuis le début oui c'est la
première manifestation dans la vie vous
étiez on va dire prédisposé à manifester
ou pas qu'est ce que vous faites au
quotidien je suis intérimaire
je suis intérimaire et je travaille
essentiellement pour la poste les pieds
que je suis intérimaire mais j'ai un
plus long parcours professionnel
effectivement ponctuée de contrats aidés
ponctuée de deux chose comme ceci et je
pense est est représentative de ce que
de ce que montrent les gilet jaune dans
la france d'aujourd'hui vous et vous
allez intervenir pendant pendant que
pour cette émission avec nous sur ce
plateau aussi didier martin bonjour
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes député la
république en marche de coq d'or et
jean-paul carteret bonjour bonsoir vous
êtes maire de larrau cours en haute
saône et vous êtes le président des
maires ruraux de votre département et
vice-président national cn europe et
cela vous pourrez donc réagir à ces
reportages et nous donner votre
sentiment au fil de la soirée et cette
soirée nous la commençons avec un
portrait un portrait en jaune
céline roy à 22 ans elle a été l'une des
figures emblématiques du mouvement gilet
jaune à vesoul en haute-saône
nos équipes l'ont suivie depuis le début
et aujourd'hui elle souhaite se lancer
en politique vous allez le voir
c'est un reportage de frédérique buridan
philippaerts baisse thomas hardy et
câline saison
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
hassanein
[Musique]
puis maman mes trois enfants j'ai 22 ans
je suis commercial
je suis la personne lambda foyer moyen
aujourd'hui avec les autres gilets elle
a appris la nouvelle
moi c'est hors de question abbey sa vie
papale qu'on n'a jamais vus sur une
manif mes parents sont ouvriers
ma mère était femme fanny on n'a jamais
connu faisant n'est pas déjà partis en
vacances les choses comme ça donc c'est
vrai qu'il ya toujours eu cette
injustice là pourtant et par an
c'est le 17 novembre dernier que tout a
commencé
ce fameux samedi où des milliers de
français ont décidé de se donner rendez
vous sur des ronds points dans la rue
avec un gilet jaune pour exprimer leur
mécontentement
céline était l'une des organisatrices à
vesoul et elle était loin d'imaginer que
ce fameux samedi allait modifier le
cours de sa vie
ce 17 novembre tombe complètement la
veille du 17 novembre on a fait une
réunion en me disant on arrête tout fou
parce qu'on pensait et 30 au milieu d'un
rond point que ça allait pas du tout
fonctionné donc
non jamais on n'aurait pensé qu'il y ait
autant de monde c'était exactement le
style chine c'était on s'est retrouvé à
1500 sur un point on ne devient pas je
pense que c'est ce que les gens qui
disent bon bah voilà enfin c'est ça j'ai
été la personne qui a fait le 17
novembre donc c'était logique entre
guillemets que ce soit moi qui porte la
parole et tout ça après il y aurait eu
quelqu'un qui me disait t'es pas t'es
pas assez compétente
enfin quelqu'un dans la vraie vie et
passionné réseaux sociaux qui m'aurait
dit t'es pas compétente je pense que je
suis plus compétents que toi allez
prendre la parole du régime et vas-y
foncé à la tombée de la nuit on verra
qui restera et puis s'il faut rester ben
ben on attendra le 17 novembre on voit
qu'il ya trois personnes qui ont déclaré
cette manifestation dont cette fameuse
céline wahsington femmes vous êtes
surpris de voir ces personnes à la tête
de cette manif il ya 2 2 leader officiel
de la manifestation il ya effectivement
céline roy qui sort un peu de nulle part
effectivement qu'on n'a jamais rencontré
auparavant dans la vie publique
brésilienne et haut saônoise et puis un
autre personnage qui va disparaître très
vite d'ailleurs et finales femmes
effectivement céline roy s'impose avec
un certain charisme il faut bien
l'avouer comme étant la porte parole du
mouvement pas toujours écoutés pas
toujours
on va dire respecter dans les consignes
qu'elle peut donner ou qu'elle peut
improviser
je pense que j'ai une capacité d'écouté
assez car ces fortes je peux écouter un
jeune de 18 ans comme une amie 86 ans et
je serais même plus tourné vers la 4e
saison parce que moi je supporte pas les
injustices et ce qui se passe
actuellement c'est plus qu'une injustice
un mouvement qui va s'inscrire dans la
durée il faut donc s'organiser
céline prend les commandes
j'ai les dégâts quand 40 50 ans c'est
pas facile non plus parce que faut pas
oublier que les gens ils sont en colère
donc quand on leur ai dit voilà il est
17h faut rentrer chez soi parce que ça
devient dangereux
là il n'y a pas d'éclairage a marché un
très bon sur complet les dents mais il
faut rester ou à la canne
le dialogue avec la police aussi les
renseignements territoriaux les et au
final on est là fort esti soit quoi
intervention à peu plus pour déloger
nous sommes le mardi 20 novembre les
gendarmes mobiles des loges les gilets
jaunes sur le rond-point de noidans les
vesoul
un premier acte qui va marquer les
esprits là j'ai une injustice les
terribles mais là ça a été vraiment le
coup de massue
parce que pacifique sans armes sans rien
on distribue des roses rouges des roses
blanches aux gendarmes pour dire
attention les pacifistes on ne veut pas
que le coup-franc patients et au final
38 les après on au gaz a pu l'être le
gel ouais c'est eu très très peur des
gendarmes mobiles et un premier rendez
vous avec la justice pour céline elle
est arrêtée et conduite au commissariat
de police de mossoul
placé en garde à vue pendant quelques
heures
lui est reproché la non-déclaration de
cette manifestation devant le
commissariat les gilet jaune attend de
sa sortie sur moi mais c'est pas ça qui
va nous arrêter quoi au nom à bah oui ça
continue puis je pense que ça va
continuer de plus belle
et peut-être plus fort et là j'avais
mais j'avais la rage parce que pour moi
c'était pas normal qu'on fasse ça enfin
c'était alors c'était pas normal qu'on
bloque les gens allaient bosser ça je le
conçois totalement ne s'était pas normal
que d'un côté on soit puni parce qu on
manifestait qu'on disait qu'on était pas
content enfin il s'était pour tous et
surtout que ça se passait très bien et
ça a choqué beaucoup de gens parce que
il y avait des gens que tu étais papoul
et gilet jaune qui au final se sont dits
relatant enfin complètement pacifistes
et au final edition gaz et c'est quand
même c'est quand même grave
un épisode qui va renforcer la
détermination de céline et des autres
gilet jaune
les actions coup de poing se mettent en
place des rendez vous improvisé comme
avec le président du conseil
départemental de haute saône
et puis direction la gare de vesoul avec
un seul objectif le blocage d'un train
de voyageurs à destination de paris
on est chic de
d'attaquer un peu l'état on fait tout
simplement notre niveau alors moi j'ai
expliqué à les brûler des radars ou
cassés et cédera ça va pas du tout nous
apporter parce que c'est nous qui allons
payer via nos impôts s'inscrit tam en
rien par contre aller bloquer un train
c'est intéressant ce train justement ce
blocage va valoir à céline un deuxième
rendez-vous avec la justice
une nouvelle convocation au commissariat
deux halls et c'est avec tous les gilet
jaune qu'elle s'y rend à l'extérieur ils
ne le savent pas encore mais céline va
entamer une nouvelle garde à vue
j'y vais 1
j'arrive dans le bureau il dit bien
placé en garde à vue à partir de 9h30
on m'a choqué fin cents soit plus choqué
que ça par contre choqué parce qu'on
m'avait dit que j'allais ressortir
quelques heures après et au final pas du
sort je pensais pas que healy rae
certaines personnes qui allaient
reprendre le flambeau je pensais pas et
qu'ils avaient faux at-elle bornet et je
pensais surtout pas qu'ils aient autant
de monde deux jours je suis sortie du
tribunal
24 heures plus tard direction le
tribunal correctionnel de vesoul
céline passent en comparution immédiate
le procureur de la république demande
lui mois de prison avec sursis
finalement elle en sera condamnée à 2 à
la sortie ces soutiens de la première
heure la réconforte et là j'étais
vraiment en stand by jeux jeux j'y vais
mais dans ma tête j'étais complètement
où j'avais décroché pas moi je
décrochais chalet suisse possible
j'avais entendu ce qu'on me disait ne
réalisez pas du tout que j'avais pu
permis que je devais 800 balles sdf dont
je réalisais pas quoi et un jeu sort
j'ai 200 personnes qui me tombe dessus
l'immédiat les machins et ruisseaux
côtiers et après je rentre chez moi et
je rentre chez moi ça va un jour deux
jours quatre régions du match aller
parce que parce qu'au final on a beau
dire bon bah ça va on a beau avoir tout
soutien du monde entier enfin j'étais
seul en cellule
à ses côtés depuis le début
son mari joe hahn qui la soutient
l'écoutent et traverse avec elles toutes
ces pages d'histoire qui s'écrivent
depuis le 17 novembre dernier son
soutien ça a été même encore maintenant
ça il ya beaucoup de choses où il me
tempère un peu oui beaucoup
non ils calment ils raisonnent et enfin
moi je prends beaucoup les choses à
coeur lui il va plus avoir de recul et
voilà non mais c'est enfin je pense que
sans lui je n'aurais pas fait un quart
de ce que j'ai fait là son taux dans des
précieuses ça a changé bien évidemment
ça va changer
elle a pris encore plus de maturité ils
sont son jeune âge mais non ça change ça
forge et une personne franchement même
moi même enfin tout le monde tout ce
qu'elle a vécu sur le rond point je
pense que c'est ça on va prendre
ouais on vivra plus la même façon
maintenant avant avant cette
mobilisation c'est un nouveau combat qui
attend céline maintenant le 14 janvier
dernier elle a décidé de se lancer en
politique
elle rejoint la france insoumise le
mouvement de jean luc mélenchon avec en
ligne de mire le calendrier électoral de
ces prochains mois et pourquoi pas les
municipales de 2020
[Musique]
rajoutons que céline a été convoqué à
nouveau par la justice il lui est
reproché des propos outrageant à
l'encontre du préfet de haute saône
sabrina morio la fin du reportage nous
dit que ces dîners lé veut se lancer en
politique ce qu'est le questionnement
qu'on a depuis le début vu de
l'extérieur sur ce mouvement est ce
qu'il est politique est ce qu'il n'est
pas politique elle est atypique cette
jeune fille par rapport au reste du
mouvement
je pense jeu de mon analyse personnelle
longtemps que moi même sabrina gilet
jaune
il ya trois mouvances visiblement qui
qui se détermine il ya une partie
déterminée qui demande la démission
sinéquanone du gouvernement de macron
etc et la mise en place d'une démocratie
participative immédiate
il ya d'autres personnes qui souhaitent
et c'est ce que c'est ce qui a l'air de
se dégager qui partage le souhait d'une
nouvelle vie politique mais pas
forcément une démission immédiate qui
veulent réfléchir qui veulent se réunir
qui veulent débattre qui veulent en
débattre ensemble il ya des assemblées
qui se met en place partout des réunions
sur le rythme et aussi sur d'autres sur
d'autres questions et il ya même une
assemblée générale des assemblées
générales qui va avoir lieu -la
troisième mouvance c'est pas comme comme
cette personne qui veut entrer en
politique parce que qui pense qu'on peut
changer la politique
en entrant dans celle ci il ya l'idée de
la représentation dans votre mouvement
les médias comme nous tout le monde aime
avoir quelqu'un qui en face d'eux on a
eu beaucoup de mal à avoir des
représentants et souvent les
représentants des débuts ont plus été
les représentants de la suite parce
qu'ils ont été contestées c'est aussi ce
qui s'est passé de l'intérieur dans ce
mouvement pouvant vous l'avez vécu comme
ça oui
toute personne qui qui s'est mis en
avant mais même sans forcément le
vouloir il ya eu un petit peut-être un
petit coup de bâton derrière parce que
ben on a plus confiance
tout simplement on a plus confiance à
celui qui prend la tête ce qui est à
celui qui prend la parole et à tous les
niveaux à tous les jours on a plus
confiance parce que compass cas à partir
du moment où une personne porte soit
disant la parole de d'autres à partir du
moment où une personne minimum de
pouvoir qui les y lui qu'il se soit
police à un nouveau un financier ou
politique
on s'aperçoit qu'à partir de ce moment
là il ya tout juste il ya plus de
justesse l'appui de justice donc en tout
cas celle de russell sentiment que
beaucoup de gens partagent est sûre
c'est sur ces barrages
on avance un petit peu dites-nous didier
martin et jean paul carteron on en
reparlera si ce qu'on a vu là dans ce
premier reportage c'est à dire la montée
de gens qui protestent qui veulent autre
chose c'est quelque chose qu'on sentait
déjà
est ce que les députés en marché dans
leur marche quand il était marcheurs il
l'avait vu venir ou pas du tout allez
soyons honnêtes ce mouvement il a
surpris tout le monde
on a conduit un certain nombre de
réformes et là à propos de
l'augmentation du prix de l'essence qui
était le déclencheur dans une
trajectoire écologique qui avait été
déjà anticipé et compte accélérer
on a vu ce mouvement se constituer
trouve que le reportage
il est intéressant parce qu'on voit
cette jeune femme sincère qui dit il
faut d'abord je ne mélange pas la vraie
vie et les réseaux sociaux je crois
qu'il faudra y revenir sur le rôle des
réseaux sociaux dans le mouvement parce
que c'est tout à fait inédit
ensuite elle dit on ne bloque pas les
gens qui vont bosser et puis enfin suite
à ce qui s'est passé elle a affaire à la
justice
hélas elle s'engage en politique dans un
amour
dont le but est de transformer ce
mouvement social en insurrection est en
mouvement révolutionnaire c'est pas moi
qui le dit c'est la france est soumise
ces ses porte parole donc on a
effectivement une trajectoire
intéressante dans ce témoignage
jean paul carter et je donnerai la
réponse après le la parole après le
reportage suivant qui va qui va vous
intéresser beaucoup aussi parce que ce
mouvement est inédit par les lieux où il
s'est déroulé avec une occupation des
ronds-points des changeurs de bord de
route depuis le 17 novembre un peu
partout en france des campements ont vu
le jour des installations pour rendre
constamment visible le mouvement de
contestation des gilets jaunes est
également c'était des lieux de
rencontres et d'échangés certains sont
presque devenus des communautés nous
avons choisi de nous rendre à la charité
sur loire pour voir de l'intérieur la
vie de ces installations sata reportage
de gabrielle talon et de remis aux
chutes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sixième samedi de manifestations à
nevers parmi les gilet jaune présent un
petit groupe de gaulois réfractaires
pour savoir qu'ils sont il faut se
rendre dans ce qui est un peu devenu de
plus deux mois leur village nous n'avons
pas le droit d'aller sous la tour eiffel
sachez qu'à la charité sur loire
nous allons faire une manifestation non
déclarée sous la tour eiffel sur ce
campement bord de route pas de lassitude
de l'enthousiaste même il rêve toujours
de construire ensemble qui ne se
connaissaient pas il y encore de moi
aussi belle que celle de paris c'est une
famille marque crée des liens de la
solidarité
c'est une vraie famille c'est ce qui
manquait un peu à la france de se
retrouver je pousse envoyé à la sortie
des écoles des choses comme ça on se
disait à peine bonjour ça crée du lien
social
arnaud et cadres en formation
professionnelle
mais actuellement il est au chômage
autour de lui il y à différentes
professions mais surtout une grande part
de retraités il semble organisé
déterminer pourtant ils sont loin d'être
des habitués de la contestation et des
mouvements sociaux
vous aviez déjà vécu un moment comme ça
avant la première fois quarante deux ans
de métier carrière jamais fait grève lui
ce philippe chauffeur routier à la
retraite
ici il a trouvé une nouvelle fonction au
surnomme le cuistot êtes hyper organisés
oui il faut 1 ça serait pour deux jours
ça irait mais apparemment ça c'est
monter petit à petit les gens sont 10e
dont apporter un cabinet salle à l'autre
camlez et tous les soirs et tout est
débarrassé ya plus rien ne soit point
d'orgue de chaque journée le moment du
déjeuner là encore l'esprit gaulois
domine celui des repas des fans de bd
d'astérix mais en fait je fais presque
dommage que demain le gouvernement
décide d'accéder à vos revendications
voilà dans tous les camps ne se quittera
pas ça c'est certain
ces deux fois
être enfant c'est vraiment les gaulois
toujours ensemble la bonne bouffe le
meut le midi on viole on ment il n'y a
pas que des moments festifs sur le
campement
un instant solennel ici en mémoire des
personnes décédées en marge du mouvement
il y a aussi les discussions autour du
feu où chacun raconte ses problèmes de
femmes noires son ras-le-bol des taxes
aussi son sentiment d'être délaissés
tchestine par exemple elle vit
actuellement avec 600 euros par mois une
pension de veuvage qui s'arrêtera
bientôt je travaillais avant dans les
vignes maintenant au travail puisque
c'est pas pour être méchante mais
déroule un bail nous baisse admettons en
450 euros à l'hectare
il rend compte que 150 ans après
tabbou s'avoue plus de coup d'aller
travailler c'est ça que non non je n'ai
pas travaillé pour 150 euros à l'hectare
chacun participe à sa façon et on
demande et il est jeune pourtant les
colonels ya pas de prix merci beaucoup
et parmi les gilet jaune de la charité
il y a même un anglais james un écrivain
installé depuis peu dans la région le
mouvement français pour lui c'est le
symptôme de l'époque tu crois que la
même chose se passe peu partout dans le
monde aux tiers mais pour moi tu crois
que le monde entier nous le mieux gaz
parce que pour moi les français et les
françaises vialis très bien et c'est par
les pairs sonoma qui font de la révolte
c'est les prêts sont tous des gars comme
moi qui fais un très bon goût et aux
propos dorénavant la politique
ces hommes et ces femmes comptent bien
se mêler et pas qu'une fois tous les
cinq ou six noms nous maintenant à la
charité on est reçu à leur rencontre
nous nous ouvrons peu probable on est
reçu par tous les élus prg 1
tous les élus autour d'une table et il
faut qu'on aille dans la liste sadia
toit ce qui sont rendu compte qu'on
n'était pas bon donc maintenant faut
lire loin on leur a dit qu'ils aillent
se faire au cul qu'on allait se
présenter et on ira au bout et on va la
prendre la mairie c'est certain on va la
prendre
ce soir-là il quitte le campement
direction la salle des fêtes
c'est la présentation des voeux de la
députée la république en marge de la
circonscription des runes boulet bonjour
sûr vous allez bien je vous souhaite on
vous souhaite comme changeant nos
meilleurs voeux
mais pas pour commencer pour cette
occasion de le faire des bêtises
c'est gentil mais gentil et un beau
gilet jaune pourrait on penser encore à
nous et je pense à vous sur la
production qui avait fait de déplacer
et portiques de sécurité à l'entrée de
la france pour attraper les les
étrange et oui à priori ça se heurte à
une un problème européen
donc je pense que ça il fera quoi
soulève on la campagne européenne ok
parce que c'est une discrimination dans
la circulation européen mais je trouvais
ça intéressant donc faut peut-être qu'on
regarde sur cette partie el proposer des
réformes et être consultés avant les
prises de décision un souhait à l'image
du hérissé qu'il réclame et qu'ils
obtiendront peut-être mais d'ici là ce
samedi matin au campement
c'est le même rituel hebdomadaire un
mouvement comme ça est ce qu'on va faire
on apprend seulement surtout rappelé
faut que l'eau aujourd'hui je pense moi
voilà déjà on va se démarquer des
défenseurs se voit déjà quand tu vois
des guignols un peu farfelu déguiser la
sécurité aura sept gendarmes je pense
tout haut
c'est très bien si on part en garde à
vue allez voir si heureux de se
retrouver pour chaque manifestation on
les imagine presque devenir triste si le
mouvement devait s'arrêter demain on a
envie que ça s'arrête on a envie de
rentrer chez nous on sache et comprend
pas forcément du plaisir est là tous les
samedis et toutes les semaines mais
voilà on n'a pas envie que ça s'arrête
parce qu'on a envie de conserver
l'esprit d'amitié qu'on a tout son sens
et on se transformera sous d'autres
formes association ou autre mais enfin
on continuera après avoir mais oui on a
envie que le mouvement s'arrête
mais qu'on accède à leurs revendications
tout simplement impossible de savoir
pour l'heure la traces que laissera dans
l'histoire le mouvement des gilets
jaunes
ce qui est certain c'est qu'il restera
pour les gaulois de la charité et pour
tant d'autres une incroyable aventure
humaine
jean-paul carteret vous avez acquis et
c'est en voyant le reportage quand les
gens évoqué le lien nouveau enfin ce
manque de lien un maire rural comme vous
il l'a vue venir ça ce manque de liens
actuels dans notre société
j'en ris dire d'emblée ça fait une
quarantaine d'années que les maires
ruraux tire la sonnette d'alarmé sur le
manque de considération pour les
territoires ruraux sur la pauvreté qui
s'installent dans les territoires ruraux
puisque la tendance et l'exode rural et
donc la pauvreté continue d'exister au
départ moi j'ai envie de dire c'est
l'art de vivre qu'on vient de voir ce
rond point l'art de vivre à la campagne
l'art de vivre des gens dans un village
de lien social que nous fait pourquoi il
existe plus
il veut dire qu'il existe il est inutile
et il existe mais à la campagne il
existe encore autour du maire les gens
vont trouver le maire et les gens
s'expriment vivent ensemble à la sortie
de l'école comme vous l'avez dit et est
ce qui s'est passé j'ai envie de dire
qu'au départ on avait tous un petit
gilet jaune dans la tête
ma mère à 800 euros de retraite j'ai
compris tout de suite le souci j'ai
autour de moi des gens qui sont familles
monoparentales qui ont du mal qui sont
des travailleurs pauvres comme on dit on
a compris au départ et autour de nous
n'est pas que des gilets jaunes et on
entendait des gens qui lisent baruya
sayah j'ai ça et je regarde la
télévision c'est pas du tout comme ça ce
qui se passe en vie
c'est pas pareil et donc on n'a pas été
surpris nous et c'est pour ça que on a
mis en place les ouvert les mairies pour
recueillir les doléances et je peux
confirmer et là que les gens ils avaient
vraiment envie de parler de s'exprimer
de dire les choses comme ils le
ressentent comme ils le vivent
et ça leur a donné envie de parler bien
les choses
gilet jaune ou pas on va y revenir sur
ce qui les doléances un mot sur les
lieux des ronds-points des parkings des
c'est plutôt de mon avis un pdc des
lieux sans ça c'est d'ouvrir ces lieux
sans histoire puis sa tour parce que
disons qu'il ya du monde autour puisque
ça arrive dans tous les sens je sais pas
peut-être vous pouvez nous expliquer
pourquoi les ronds points
mais voilà c'était un lieu de
rassemblement alors en amour alors
sabrina pour pourquoi des quelqu'un a
écrit les ronds points ont permis aux
invisibles de devenir visibles et rond
point comme monsieur le maire l'a dit
c'est l'endroit où tout le monde passe
un nom de sa journée et c'est donc c'est
là où nous sommes visibles c'est là où
on peut bloquer pour la housse ait
évoqué dimension symbolique à plus une
dimension efficace que symbolique pour
les rentrants je pense que c'est une
dimension effectivement efficace pour
les parkings invite non ce qu'il ya une
symbolique derrière le parking d'un
signe d'un grand centre commercial etc
ont déjà il ya de la place pour se
réunir et puis le commerce etc tout ce
qui tout ce qui va derrière ben
justement la voiture c'est la voiture
qui a tout déclenché ces taxes sur
l'essence et le gilet jaune ce soir là
dans l'autre voiture et c'était tout à
fait naturel
les temps changent et c'est quelque
chose qui a peut-être pas été vu au
moment de ces mesures
au moins neuf ans en tout cas pas
apprécié sa juste valeur azur l ont
suivie en novembre et 1 de sol de
l'importance vous parliez des parkings
de supermarché de l'économie ça nous
amène justement à notre sujet suivant
puisque à côté des ronds-points le
mouvement s'est caractérisée par 10 à
12h samedi une manifestation en partie
pendant les fêtes de fin d'année pendant
les soldes avec parfois des
affrontements
la fréquentation des centres villes a
été très impacté plusieurs associations
de commerçants demandent d'ailleurs 2
aujourd'hui quelles sont les
conséquences économiques de ce mouvement
réponse en haute saône dans le doubs
dans le jura avec amandine plougoulm et
laurent brocard l'état soit pour le
commerce
c'est le moment que les jaunes sacré ça
crée un climat anxiogène qui est pas bon
pour les affaires qui est bon pour
personne elle à l'action et le franc
suisse à se faire entendre du
gouvernement surtout est dérangé
l'économie on va dire pas l'arrêté pas
l'anéantir la déranger rien que le fait
de dire que tous les samedis va y avoir
des manifestations il ya plein de gens
qui viennent plus qu'il ya un mouvement
qui a clairement plombé
la dynamique commerciale de fin d'année
n'ont absolument pas de mal aux
commerçants pas parler des situations
catastrophiques pourquoi ça ne se
ressent pas encore bruno le maire parle
d'une catastrophe catastrophe événement
aux conséquences graves voire
irréparable et à qui en résultent ruines
des astres on a voulu voir si bruno le
maire n'avait pas un peu exagéré en
plein mois de janvier les chiffres
manquent le recul aussi sans compter que
le mouvement des gilet jaune n'est pas
non plus fini
mais ce qui ne fait pas défaut ce sont
les ressentis des gens eux les
commerçants les restaurateurs les
patrons bref tout ce qui de près ou de
loin ont été économiquement touchée par
ce mouvement
[Musique]
notre périple commence à pontarlier
connu pour être un petit eldorado la
proximité avec la frontière est souvent
gage de bonne affaire christian piot il
ya ouvert son restaurant en 2014
le père go au bord de la rn 57 ses
grandes baies vitrées donnent sur le
rond-point occupée par les gilet jaune
le 17 novembre dernier
dan est une de nos tournées entre 80 et
100 couverts sur ce jeu 7,7 cette
journée là seize couverts le midi
le midi le rond point était totalement
bloquée plus du tout d'accès pour
personnes
c'est vrai que le matin quand on est
arrivé au travail enseignement les
vraiment ce qui se passait ce jour-là à
christian piot avait fait le deuil de
ses clients mais pour une bonne pizza
cette famille d'habitués n'a pas hésité
à franchir le pas quitte à se garer 500
mètres plus loin quand ils ont vu
arriver c'est un peu surpris d'avoir des
clients parce que je pense qu'il pense
qu'il s'attendait à voir personne nous
vous voulez profiter un peu notre
journée nature et ken donc des plus
aussi faire marcher les commerçants
parce qu'on les connaissait donc
au passage ses dires il faut continuer à
sortir même si ça peut être compliqué
des fois on est à peu près stable
nous on va pas se plaindre franchement
on va vraiment pas se plaindre on a
réussi à stabiliser pourquoi parce que
justement on a élargi un petit peu notre
accueil on ailleurs j'ai un petit peu
nos horaires ce qui nous a permis un
petit peu de combler notre retard
difficile de trouver l'équilibré
financier quand un blocage se prolonge
ailleurs on franche comté c'est parfois
ce qu'il s'est passé novembre 2018 à
noidans les vesoul entre le ballet des
gilet jaune et le concert de klaxons
l'effervescence fait tourner la tête
il y en a qui est resté à l'écart du
spectacle sur un petit bout de trottoir
juste en face du rond-point en pleine
période de fêtes mathieu perreault a
rapidement déchanté son magasin de
déguisements a perdu 75 % de chiffre
d'affaires sur le mois de novembre
50 % en décembre aujourd'hui les
vestiges de ces trois semaines de
blocage sont emballés au fond de
quelques cartons bah voila il resta qui
reste tout ce qui est bonne et je n'ai
vendu un petit peu mais voyez ça pas
beaucoup diminué il ya aussi tous les
costumes la à la deux mères noël de père
noël alors ça d'habitude ça part très
très très bien en direct donc sur le
magasin en ligne aussi mais surtout en
direct donc bah là et j'ai pu en vendre
que pendant une dizaine de jours donc
forcément la période de vente étant
diminuée il en reste énormément
voilà et le souci sur ce genre de
produit c'est que dd père noël on en
vend ni en janvier ni en février ni les
mois suivants on en vend comme mois de
novembre au mois de décembre
il va falloir que je fasse un très bon
carnaval pour m'en sortir tandis que
certains commerçants font la grimace
les gilets jaunes avance avec une
revendication mettre un coup de frein à
l'économie si c'est le symbole c'est de
bloquer les grandes entreprises les gros
distributeurs les faire déranger
l'économie on va dire par l'arrêté pas
l'anéantir la déranger en matière de
commerce les gilet jaune font le
distinguo entre les grands et les petits
leclerc super u intermarché auchan les
voilà les enseignes directement visé
pour les atteindre il leur a fallu
bloquer des plates formes
d'approvisionnement déployer les
opérations escargot et mettre en place
des barrages filtrants
ce que nous ne l'est pas ce qui bloque
également le rond point qui est juste là
et qui donne accès directement au
magasin est alors leurs revendications
les comprend
par contre la cible n'est pas bonne
c'est à dire qu'ils s'attaquent aux
commerçants nous on a des salariés qu'on
doit payer aujourd'hui je mets en doute
la pérennité de nos c'est peut-être su
que ces craintes les chefs d'entreprise
les ombres remonter aux organisations
professionnelles
c'est des gens qui se pose la question
est ce que ça vaut jus de continuer
parce que là si ça continue comme ça on
va pas s'en sortir on a peur que ce
mouvement devienne un mouvement de
guerre civile dont on entend ces mots
des mots c'est faux c'est fort comme aux
mots comme guerre civile et la lente
reprise s'est dit mais moi j'ai pas les
moyens de supporter une crise sociétale
social est forcément économique derrière
dans une entreprise où j'ai déjà du mal
à l'amener à la garder à flot dans cet
océan agité les petits commerçants aussi
ont dû naviguer à vue ont ils tenu la
marée eux que les gilet jaune souhaité
est épargné après les manifestations
hebdomadaires au centre-ville des
vitrines sa fiston victimes collatérales
ils mettent tous les petits artisans les
petites entreprises comme nous en temps
j les sangliers ou
les manifestations il ya eu des blocages
pour venir au centre-ville ils ont
bloqué les bus le tram la clientèle ils
n'osaient pas venir au centre ville on a
toujours peur des débordements bien sûr
c'est normal un sage compte chaque
samedi depuis le 8 décembre les gilet
jaune des filtres à besançon mais si les
clients ont déserté le centre ville est
ce vraiment la faute des manifestations
au-delà de l'impact direct une route à
les bloquer les voitures peuvent pas
passer peuvent pas aller dans une zone
commerciale il ya un impact il ya
l'impact direct mais s'il ya vu que
celui là il n'aurait pas été viré
extraordinairement guidé par contre ça a
généré tout un ensemble de d'inquiétude
qui a réduit la halle envie de consommer
avec ce trop-plein de morosité les
consommateurs se serait donc mis à la
diète
une baisse de régime difficile à avaler
pour les petits commerces du centre
ville
vous vous dites c'est pas possible
comment je vais faire comment je vais
payer mes fournisseurs comment je vais
finir le mois
le mois et puis les mois qui vont venir
parce qu'on sait très bien que refait
une trésorerie au mois de décembre avec
sept réseaux nous permet de combler les
mois creux qui vont arriver donc comment
on fait donc ça oui voilà alors je parle
souvent mais ça fait des nuits sans
sommeil
cécile girardet ne crie pas famine mais
les provisions de sa trésorerie
s'amenuisent elle s'est donc tournée
vers sa dent pour trouver une solution
donc là deux semaines quasiment de
perdus par rapport à la wii c'est ça et
aujourd'hui moi par exemple sur mon
commerce ça représente 30% du chiffre
d'affaires de perdue donc sur une année
où je suis sur le mois sur le mois
sachant que c'est un mois qui est
primordial que pour préserver sa
trésorerie cécile à demander d'étaler le
paiement d'une taxe fiscale normalement
prélevés en décembre son banquier lui ai
suggéré cette solution mise en place par
le gouvernement
autre mesure prise par le préfet du
doubs la possibilité pour les
commerçants d'ouvrir chaque dimanche de
janvier
ça fait quatre ans que je suis sur le
post ici sur besançon je ne me rappelle
pas avoir vu ce titre ce type de mesure
c'est assez exceptionnel effectivement
exceptionnel et pourtant le mois de
décembre est un mois porteur même s'il a
été perturbé par le mouvement des gis
les jours même si les commerces ont subi
sur une baisse du chiffre d'affaires là
encore j'ai pas d'éléments très précis
prêt chiffré à ce moment là ce stade
mais la trésorerie est quand même pour
l'instant
plutôt correct maintenant est ce qu'elle
sera suffisante pour passer les
prochaines semaines voire les prochains
mois c'est autre chose
[Musique]
les banques restent vigilantes car la
situation peut vite basculer
[Musique]
pour s'en sortir
sophie olivier ne s'est pas tourné vers
la banque mais vers la toile elle a
choisi de lancer une cagnotte en ligne
et d'appeler les gilet jaune à ne plus
manifester le samedi au centre-ville
à la base on a trop de charges c'est
déjà trop dur d'être indépendant à
besançon ou ailleurs en france donc je
sais que le problème vient pas de là par
contre je sais que ce qui manque ce qui
a en france cette course c'est le début
des manifestations c'est sûr parce que
jusqu'au 17 novembre mais j'arrivais à
maintenir ce que j'ai réussi à maintenir
l'année dernière je crois que ce qu'on
vit depuis des années en france avec les
différents événements depuis depuis le
clash de 2008 2012
on a épuisé les trésoreries et les
marges de manoeuvre des entreprises dont
tout est au cordeau
tout est sur le fil et le moindre
basculement rend les choses encore plus
en plus difficile afin de ne plus mettre
en danger ses commerçants certains
manifestants ont rangé leurs giné c'est
ici à dole que l'engagement de fabrique
légal a commencé la figure est bien
connue des gilet jaune puisqu'il était
l'un des leaders du mouvement
parce que le plus important dans cette
histoire va donner coup de théâtre le 22
décembre lorsqu'il appelle à ne plus
manifester ils refusent de faire partie
d'un mouvement qui prend en otage selon
lui les petits commerçants
à force on les a impacté quand même mais
abandonné fallait qu'on stoppe parce qu'
il fallait au moins qu'ils puissent se
rattraper pendant les 15 derniers jours
de décembre pour pour au moins pouvoir
survivre
voilà c'était le sens de mon retrait
fabrice a rangé son gilet mais pas ses
convictions s'il n'était plus d'accord
sur la forme il reste d'accord sur le
fond c'est pas une catastrophe d'avoir
un peuple qui se lève abandonné quel
courage de se lever contre l'injustice
fiscale contre l'injustice sociale
contre le pouvoir d'achat en berne non
c'est pas une catastrophe c'est plutôt
sain après c'est la tournure que ça
prend
tournure aléatoire selon les endroits
car les commerçants et les gilet jaune
où vivent parfois en parfaite harmonie
[Musique]
harang saut dans le jura cj les jaunes
ont quitté le rond point et se sont
installés sur un terrain prêté par une
entreprise voisine
chaque matin le rituel est le même alain
taillard par se ravitailler à évent le
village d'à côté c'est le patron du bar
qui nous prépare le café ils nous
préparent les thermaux cependant même
sur leurs ouvrages et les gens ne cédez
coupable tout trouvé
les commerçants chute c'est l'homme cedh
à protéger les jambes
l'état va leur servir en dit long bain
on l'a pas atteint l'objectif de la
croissance
l'octave service à tout le monde que
vous regardez bien
on a empêché personne de passer les
petits commerçants continuent de
travailler s'ils ont des problèmes
c'était c'est le pouvoir d'achat qui en
est la cause
pas nous c'est trop facile il n'y a pas
de neige là où c'est la faute des gilets
jaunes
oui c'est sûr on allume des feux
réchauffement climatique non ça c'est
trop facile quoi les jets les jeux ne
sont pas là pour tous s'ils l'ont pas
non
avant nous il y avait déjà des problèmes
on les a par amplifié on a mis le doigt
dessus
certains patrons aubry conscient de ces
problèmes et ont choisi de rejoindre le
mouvement
jean-marie veil est à la tête d'une
entreprise d'élagage à besançon un
patron au profil atypique car engagé il
a décidé d'arborer un gilet jaune après
s'être fait sa propre idée du mouvement
sur le terrain la formation que je peux
avoir c'est en allant voir donc d'alors
boire ce lait rond-point discuter avec
les gens et ses draps et là j'ai été
très surpris quoi faire face aux prix de
je m'attendais pas à voir cette
population la coupe des gens tout nus
qui s'allège quoi que ce soit des
fonctionnaires ou des salaires qui s'en
sortent plus je pense qu'il ya pas que
phénomène des petit gilet jaune qui fait
que les gens consomment moi je pense
qu'effectivement il ya de plus en plus
de gens qui n'ont pas les moyens de
finir le mois
alors le terme de catastrophe était-il
vraiment approprié les comptes de la
france serait t'il dans le rouge à cause
des filets jaunes sur les plateaux télé
chacun y va de son interprétation
c'est parce qu'il est inédit que ce
mouvement ébranlé grilles de lectures
habituelles et bruire un bilan
économique encore prématuré alors viens
d'entendre tous les avis à peu près sûr
sur ce sujet didier martin vous
réagissiez pendant le reportage sur un
point c'était loin des violences pendant
les manifestations
oui on pourra aborder après mais je
pense que c'est très important
tout à fait l'ordre public doit être
respectée parce que tout simplement il
n'y a pas de liberté sans ordre public
et les manifestations quand les casseurs
prennent le dessus en fin de
manifestation en fin d'après midi c'est
pas tolérable il fallait le dire malgré
tout sur le chapitre économique le bilan
est peut-être trop tôt pour le faire
néanmoins il ya des organismes
spécialisés pour pour le dire est une
perte de une perte de richesse sur le
produit intérieur but brut
il y aura une perte d'emploi plusieurs
dizaines de milliers d'emplois
et tout ça c'est effectivement très
dommageable au développement économique
les commerçants les commerçants de
centre-ville à dijon en particulier
chaque samedi se voit très lourdement
pénalisés et pour cela il faut qu'il y
ait une prise de conscience et de
responsabilité de la part des gilet
jaune arrêté d'un vers les
centres-villes chaque samedi après-midi
que soit besançon ou dijon qu'est le
lieu de ralliement de gilet jaune de
toute l'ariège sabrina morio le la
difficulté des petits commerçants vous
l'entendez les gens et par exemple celle
à dole je crois qu'elle souhaitait ne
plus manifester à cause de ça qu'est-ce
que qu'est ce que vous y répondent riez
en répondant à l'occasion du dit martin
là dessus sur les manifestations en
centre-ville est comme une petite odeur
d'hypocrisie dans l'air quand même je
trouve
quid de la consommation si avait pas eu
ce mouvement qui nous est ce qu'on en
serait s'il n'y avait pas eu les gilet
jaune ce mouvement dit gilet jaune ou
est-ce qu'on en serait aujourd'hui dont
on sait rien jean on parle du gilet
jaune
on aurait peut-être dû se concentrer
peut-être sur ce que paye un petit
commerçant une petite
pme les taxes ses charges peut-être que
ça serait plus juste qu'on commence à
parler de ça avant de parler des gilet
jaune
si j'ai quelques secondes pour
rapidement parce qu'on doit parler du
grand débat non mais on voit très adroit
d'impôts qui sont demandées par les
petits commerçants et les petites
entreprises
et puis l'autre côté une forte demande
sociale qui correspond à plus d'impôts
donc effectivement ce mouvement ils
tirent à hue et à dia pour revenir à lui
n'a pas été dit parce qu'on est vaut
pourtant déjà pas mal quand on évoque
les gilets jaunes qui perturbe les
centre-villes mais certains un petit
commerce dans les communes rurales n'ont
pas pu être alimenté certaines fois ça
c'était embêtant et et m
un mot parce que vous représentez les
communes rurales oui sur un sentiment
qu'on peut avoir dans les grandes villes
d'avoir des manifestations de gens qui
viennent souvent beaucoup des zones
rurales par rapport au centre ville on
sait qu'on voit adele et jaune dans les
voitures dans les dents les plus les
villes sont grandes - on en voit souvent
on en voit beaucoup plus dans les zones
rurales
est ce que il ya aussi ces te dirai pas
cette agressivité mais ce rapport
compliqué aujourd'hui en france entre
les villes qui sont censés réussir et
les campagnes où c'est plus dur alors je
sais pas ce qui s'est passé au moment de
choisir d'aller en ville mais sûrement
quelque chose se rapproche de ses
fameuses fracture que nous dénonçons
depuis un moment mais en même temps on a
là en ville on est sûr d'avoir davantage
de monde est une manifestation qui
mobilise et comme on l'a vu tout à
l'heure grandir bon c'est compréhensible
quelque part ce qui n'est pas
compréhensible et rejoint monsieur
martin ce qui n'est pas compréhensible
c'est tout c'est violent c'est tout
c'est nous tous qui tout ce qui est
cassé sa sé on peut réclamer demander en
même temps puisqu'on arrive au débat ce
soir on va en parler on va en parler ça
peut vous permettre de dire ce que vous
voulez nous dire sur l'économie sabrina
mouriaux à propos de ce débat justement
il ya un certain nombre de points qui je
vais renversé micro c'est pas bien c'est
mal donc deux points qui sont proposés
est ce que il ya des choses qui vous
vous semble absolument primordiale dans
ce débat qu'il faut aller dire ou pas
parce que vous vouliez nous parlait
justement de l'économie et des
difficultés de vivre ce que d'un certain
nombre de gens il est bien pour ça ce
débat ou pas de votre point de vue je
pense que ce qui est important de
rappeler ce qu'ils sont et gilet jaune à
la bassin
deux travailleurs la majorité la grande
majorité grande grande majorité ce sont
des travailleurs de toutes sortes
les trail à des prêts travailleurs
précaires des smicards etc
pour en revenir à l'économie
j'aimerais expliquer vraiment très
brièvement ce qui se passe dans la vie
du français moyen qui savent elles la
base en fin d'année en fin d'année après
le retour des vacances je vais dire
entre parenthèses c'est un autre débat
vire rapidement la plupart des gilet
jaune ne parte en vacances parce qu'ils
n'en n'ont pas les moyens mais mettons
ça entre parenthèses il y a les vacances
ensuite il y à la rentrée scolaire
on va mettre ça entre parenthèse parce
qu'on a la rentrée scolaire on pourrait
en débattre etc
n'empêche que on paye la rentrée
scolaire derrière ça y'a les impôts
payent les impôts
ensuite il ya les impôts locaux moi
personnellement je me suis pris 140 %
cette année à dijon centre 140% j'ai
tout vérifié ans j'ai refait les calculs
j'ai pris ce sont 40 % ça fait mal ce
qui fait qu'à noël alors que l'année
dernière j'avais à peu près acheté 5
cadeau à mon enfant cette année il a eu
un cadeau parce que je pouvais pas j'ai
pas mangé de gibier j'ai pas mangé de
dante et pourtant qu'est ce qui s'est
passé de particulier dans cette année
par rapport à la précédente et alors il
ya tout ce que je viens de vous décrire
que le français moyen
le gilet jaune mais le français au sens
large celui de la base les durement
impactées et donc pendant ce temps là
qu'est ce qui s'est passé la goutte
d'eau l'essence de la contestation
pendant tout ce temps là que vont payer
tout ça tout ce que je viens de vous
décrire ces quatre points il ya les sens
qui augmente et à l'augmenter à
l'essence qui en grain comme moi en
quelques semaines elle est maintenant
moins cher qu'au début du mouvement
mesures en faveur du pouvoir d'achat
avait confié la république sur le
pouvoir d'achat sur la pause sur les
augmentations de tarifs aussi pendant
tous pendant cette fin d'année qu'on vit
tous tous les ans a la base je parle de
la base de la population
il y a les sens les sens et l'essence
est tout de suite dans notre
portefeuille
c'est quand on va à la pompe hop on mêle
on met la carte bleue s'est directement
intacte juste un mot parce qu'on a bien
compris ça et on entendu depuis début du
mouvement sur le fait qu'il y avait
aussi l'argument écologique
environnementale réchauffement de la
planète
vous l'entendez ou pas et après on parle
du grand débat qu'est ce qui nous reste
quelques minutes mais vous l'entendez ou
pas cet argument qu'est-ce qu'on
entendra le sud du tout et au départ
c'était on se rappelle qu'il y avais je
pas combien 70% de français qui étaient
pour des mesures environnementales
contre le réchauffement et un mois avant
le début de la crise on est bien
d'accord mais c'est toujours le cas le
gilet jaune
le gilet jaune il a envie de changer sa
manière de consommer le problème c'est
qu'il ne le peut pas
voilà jean paul carteron ce débat les
maires ruraux avait commencé avec des
cahiers de doléances souvent beaucoup
est ce que c'est une bonne idée pour
vous est ce qu'il faut vous allez dans
votre commune organisée vous pensez
qu'il faut en organiser partout et c'est
un moment
est ce que c'est bien du tout est ce que
c'est une hypocrisie ou est ce que c'est
un virage dans le fonctionnement de
notre pays voilà on va dire ça va vous
poser la question simplement c'est
inédit en france c'est inédit en france
est temps que là où ils resteront sur un
nuage et que les gilets jaunes resteront
sur les ronds-points on n'avancera pas
c'est ce que nous pensons donc le moment
est venu de dire les choses
vous dites là haut vous aurez des gens
qui sont là où depuis longtemps noté
depuis longtemps ce que nous vivons
aujourd'hui c'est pas le résultat d'une
ou deux années c'est le résultat de
vingt années de manque de considération
pour les territoires et c'est pour ça
qu'on a surtout vu dans les territoires
ruraux ou des gilets jaunes c'est pour
ça parce que un moment donné on disait
c'est la double peine mais là c'est
l'addition des peines pas de transports
en commun donc quand les deux personnes
qui travaillent dans le couple c'est la
voiture tous les deux voitures tous les
jours le carburant le 80 km/heure enfin
tout ça qui s'additionnent et après on
comprend une colère qui s'est déclenchée
qui a commencé gentiment on va dire
comme ça puis après
qui est monté tu as grandi et d'où cette
difficulté nous avons recueilli les
doléances où on a entendu la volonté de
l' envie de parler de nombreux français
dans nos communes rurales de s'exprimer
auprès du maire mais on ne sait surtout
pas mal et on attend à donner les
cahiers les gens ont rédigé nous avons
remis emmanuel macron les doléances de
plus de 5000 communes en france et nous
avons arrêté de regarder doléances pour
qu'il n'y ait pas de confusion avec le
dessin débat attendant que nous voulons
faciliter pour les raisons que je viens
de vous dire après je crois que dans
trois mois
le gouvernement sera avec un devoir de
résultat devant lui alors des démarches
ont voulu réagir voulais je crois que
les mères mais aussi les associations
les syndicats les citoyens ont tous leur
rôle à jouer dans ce grand débat s'est
ouvert cet inédit
aucun sujet n'est tabou vous avez parlé
du pouvoir d'achat vous avez parlé de la
fiscalité c'est très important et à la
façon de vivre de se loger de se
chauffer de se déplacer tous ces sujets
sont ouverts y compris la vie citoyenne
a vu des notes démocratique de notre
pays
est ce qu'il ya un danger en creux de
pas en tenir compte au point un point
extrême et que ça se retourne contre
vous oui et c'est pour ça qu'il y a je
dirai au niveau national une
organisation qui se met en place pour
assurer la transparence des débats la
fidélité de ce qui a été dit dans les
débats pour que ça soit portée et bien
structuré ça va pas être simple mais il
faut et s'égare en s'égarant du débat
national
ils vont exercer tout le rôle avec les
blessés ce grand débat c'est la feuille
de route du gouvernement jusqu'à la fin
de son quinquennat dinars
il n'est pas de ma responsabilité de
veut dire cela mais le président de la
république a très clairement dit c'est
l'acte 2 de mon mandat
il entend s'appuyer sur cette
concertation nationale ce grand débat
pour proposer des changements aux
français hilares à la responsabilité de
choisir la méthode pour faire valider ce
changement vous faut qu'elle nous dise
oui il faut qu'elle nous dise ce qu'elle
en pense parce que hein vous allez
participer vous vous allez aller dans
des réunions vous pensez que c'est une
bonne idée
et comment vous jugerez la réussite de
sa de trois questions d'une suis
d'accord mais reste de l'île
alors vraiment pour résumer quand même
l'ensemble des des 14 des catégories de
personnes la question n'est plus est-ce
qu'on change le système vraiment je
pense qu'on est tous d'accord mais
qu'est ce qu'on propose
et comment le mettre en place c'est
compliqué c'est compliqué parce qu'on se
réunisse en association on se réunit son
syndicat c'est compliqué parce qu'en
france on sait pas faire on ne sait pas
faire son syndicat on ne sait pas faire
sans quand son intermédiaire un corps
intermédiaires qui a des locaux qui a
des moyens et qui a l'expérience de
faire des débats de les instruire et
c'est nous ben on apprend et ça fait dix
semaines qu'on apprend c'est long déjà
il faut cracher la colère parce que nous
sommes en colère je vous ai donné
quelques points tout à l'heure la
fiscalité
nos charges et c'est ce qu'on paye dans
la vie de tous les jours et cette colère
pour arriver à quelque chose de
constructif
il faut qu'elle sorte donc plein de
réunions qui dans l'absolu ne savent à
rien juste à à cracher sa pour après
arriver a dit qu'il nous reste une
minute des doléances dans des tons purs
si oui ou non vous ça vous semble une
bonne idée ce débat c'est très très
important on a la parole on a pris la
parole il faut qu'on continue il faut
surtout qu'on arrive à dégager des
choses claires pas forcément qu'on se
mettre d'accord il ya plusieurs
mouvances mais il faut qu'on décortique
les choses et qu'on en discute et qu'on
les pose sur la table
eh bien merci ça pourrait être une bonne
fin jean paul wertret j'aurais aimé vous
redonner la parole mais c'est la fin de
notre émission merci à vous d'être venu
sur notre plateau et merci aux équipes
dans un contexte compliqué d'avoir
réussi à nous raconter l'histoire de ces
10 semaines
pas comme les autres pour notre pays
bonne soirée au revoir et merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]